i love talking to this man i love
watching him on tv you can watch him on
good morning football every single
weekday morning at 7 a.m eastern time on
nfl network and you can also now stream
his work right here on peacock and
frogger he is none other than kyle
brandt back here on the rich eisens show
how are you sir
rich you just scroll through instagram
hoping to find anything that makes you
stop anything that catches your eye yes
and today for me it was the words the
raiders signed justin fargus to a
three-year contract this offseason are
you kidding me what was that card please
give context i love this thing here it
is uh so kyle brandt as you know out
here on the west coast you're holding
down the east coast fort for for us in
the nfl media group on good morning
football every day uh with your
colleagues uh out here we have switched
places from our first spot in culver
city where we turned the lights on in
2003 to a new beautiful spot across the
street from sofi
and i used to have an office at the old
culver city spot because i did total
access every day and then when i was off
of that daily show i still had a space a
workspace that i'd go into about three
four years ago they reached out to me
said hey we've run out of space here do
you mind if you just no longer have a
space here because you're not here all
that much that you used to be i'm like
no problem i just don't know when i'm
going to come to clear the stuff out
they said we're going to clear it out
for you
and i have not seen those boxes until
three days ago
because they would have moved so
literally i've been opening stuff up and
and one of the things was this card yeah
that i had i don't know why it was saved
i don't know why it was in a box but it
was from a 2008 nfl total access
where it in the b block of the show we
had adam schefter come on who was the
information man
uh at the time of the nfl network and
some of the nuggets were you know hey
adam the raiders just signed justin
fargus to a three-year deal this
off-season then they traded darren
mcfadden but lamont jordan's still in
oakland as well what's going on there
was the question
well i'll get to lamont jordan rich but
first i have to tell you free agent
running back kevin jones has cancelled
his saturday workout
it's so good
rich i'm gonna pile onto this so let me
let me try this together here so you're
talking brady coming in
winning super bowls losing super bowls
uh the man who cost him two of those
super bowls uh eli manning yes i am
talking with him later this afternoon
coming on to the 10 questions podcast is
coming out fabulous the reason i bring
this up
is that i'm doing all this research on
eli
and uh i want to talk to him about his
draft the 04 draft and the chargers
thing and how weird that was and the
picture with holding up the charger so
i'm doing all this research so i just
type in i want to see
the commissioner announcing the pick so
the video that comes up is you and 04 in
studio and you're laying it out and
you're like an eli manning comes out
twice and says he does not want to be
with the chargers they still wouldn't
pick eli anyway would they and then here
comes the clip and it's been picking
them and you look incredible and the set
looks so old compared to the one now but
it's all coming up kind of retro right
now it is it really is especially since
you know
uh philip rivers was swapped for him and
and big ben is the last one standing and
now he's got a peck injury steelers
this week with a with a big game at home
against cincinnati i mean it it there's
everything is retro is new and brady is
obviously the the retro the most retro
newest thing that's maybe been in the
history of sports today is the 20th
anniversary of mo lewis hitting drew
bledsoe and started like releasing that
brady from the bottle um i don't know if
there's any we were talking before the
show is there anything
in sports like a life-changing sliding
door moment
that even compares
to that brady getting knocked into a
game right you know um
the the trailblazers took sam bowie uh
in front of michael jordan that's one
we've seen a lot of bad draft picks that
if if mo lewis just doesn't hit blood so
we change everything um and that's not
just sports brady is now part of
american history like there are kids
will learn about him not in in pe class
in history class that's he is he's like
one of the kennedys or something it's
that big of a deal and we haven't even
gotten to him going back to foxborough
which we will do in about 10 days i know
and that's the way i led the show
because we're kind of seeing that
already i also opened the door for you
uh kyle um you know and it's okay that
you didn't walk through it it's it's
fine i i it was a slightly ajar uh you
you could have said whoever knocked andy
dalton out of that week two game against
cincinnati you could have gone in there
you could have gone in that direction
you know that was a clever door
you didn't see it you didn't see it like
a sliding glass door and i walked right
into it
um because there is nobody there there's
no mo lewis there's a non-contact bone
bruise whatever that means
here's the deal um there's a feeling
right now with the bears of
ready or not here he comes i don't i
don't know if if they're ready if he's
ready but
the bears fans and the bears coaching
staff gets to play with their toy this
weekend their their big bright shiny toy
and my takeaway even before the game
even happens i'm already taken away is
it's a big day for fields but it's a
huge day for matt maggie um
matt maggie
has to show us he knows how to drive the
ferrari he's never driven a ferrari as
the chicago bears head coach the uh i
guess we'll call it a pt cruiser is out
with that bone bruise and the ferrari
now man maggie let's go
let's do this this is a guy the most
interesting thing about him in his home
life in his background is he has a
basement matt maggie the head coach of
the bears or a man cave that is actually
physically wallpapered with play sheets
that he has had from over his career as
a play caller in kansas city and going
back that's the wallpaper he post them
all over and as a reminder of he is a
play caller this is what he does he's
creative he's a he has all sorts of
ingenuity let's see it because last week
the bears fans take away was that justin
fields every single pass attempt that he
had was inside the pocket and we got a
guy running 4-4 so matt nagy for god's
sake
empty the bag
run this guy roll them out boot like him
do everything you can possibly do
because i think this the take away if if
fields is shaky bear smells gonna come
after naggy if the play calling isn't
really fun let's play with this toy the
good thing kyle is that the bar is not
set very high in terms of chicago and
famous ferrari cruises uh related to
chicago right like cameron uh set the
bar very low in terms of taking out a
ferrari
relating to chicago from ferris
bueller's day off right so that's this
is the most important and it's not only
that cameron lived in lake forest where
the bears facility is set up it's
practically right down the street when
he crashed his father morris fry's
ferrari out the back of it and uh listen
i think they made a big enough
impression just kicking it a few times
and then the effect that went out the
back of it way way way way uh disastrous
so i would hope that the fields debut as
a ferrari goes much better than morris
fry's 1960 ferrari california it's
indeed yes indeed the 250 gt california
spider you know look
but here's the thing and you and i have
chopped this up for weeks and months now
we're here i'm just again mystified
why it's fine for
for the jets and the jaguars to just
throw their first round choice out there
doesn't matter take your lumps and then
the patriots surround their guy with a
system and just hammer it into his head
and he's perfectly built for it now
the offensive line may be the difference
maker here but why is justin fields just
viewed as yeah he's got to take his time
we got to take our time with him he's
not ready is is it entirely possible
that he doesn't know the playbook that
he cannot spit out the plays he cannot
put it in his head into from his ears to
his brain to his heart to his body is
that entirely
possible like are we going to see
somebody so unready
i don't know for a second right
i just don't um
line up any box you want to line up and
i'll put a big fat check mark in it in
the college experience the level of play
the going up against chase young in
practice at ohio state the height the
speed the accuracy the deep ball
everything i i think he should have been
taking second quarter back in the draft
after lawrence i still do so fine they
didn't they like the other guys better
but what is it because
everyone wants to bring up well
rogers sat and brady sat they didn't sit
by an any dolphin roger sat behind a
legend brady sat behind a superstar
that's why they sat
so what is it it's not as if okay andy
don't know what he is i blame him for
nothing it's not even if he's been there
for a couple years and has some equity
build up he's just as new as fields is
and yet for some reason he seems
unimpeachable unless we have the bone
bruise from the heavens
it is gonna be fascinating to see it all
play out because if he does ball out
it'll be like well why the hell did he
start for the first two weeks but then
we can turn the page and he's balled out
right unless
you know you don't think like he balls
out dalton's knees better and then all
of a sudden they put him back in the box
that just can't happen i just think he's
out there and they're just gonna have to
rip the knob off that's it take your
lumps and go
that's it it depends what happens and we
were chewing on this this morning so
uh the bears win they win
17 to 13 and field is shaky but they get
the win
dalton get a clean bill health is maggie
saying all right i told you i told you
honey dogs are starting when he's
healthy you're going right back in or if
it feels really good and they lose i i
don't know the limit of the resolve that
matt maggie has in mandy dalton but it
is seemed like almost a religious
experience his commitment to himself i
think anything is possible short of
feels going absolutely ballistic and
throwing four touchdowns but then i'm
telling you we may be having this
conversation in a week about oh my god
they announced andy dalton is back in it
would not surprise me well i mean look
the guy again matt neggie came on this
show week after the draft said this is
the plan this is the plan i saw it work
out with my homes i saw it work out i
kind of you know gingerly pointed out
that dalton isn't even alex smith
because he just showed up there as you
pointed out alex smith had years in the
system and certainly years built up with
a fan base that who that adored him you
know so um i can't wait like this is a
huge one that on the marquee that might
not be as big on other people but i i
you know i i i can't wait to see this
whole thing uh play out what what other
games kyle bryant are you looking
forward to i'll tell you what
i there's
the kansas city chiefs have lost two out
of three
now they welcome uh the prince who was
promised in the afc west this kid who we
were told is going to be the one to
fight mahomes for the next 10 years in
justin herbert justin herbert has never
played at arrowhead stadium with full
capacity he has never played against uh
patrick mahomes in arrowhead stadium
this will be the first time
and he gets patrick with holmes after
mahomes just lost to lamar the guy who
he never loses to so this one has big
time stakes because
if herbert goes in there and it's just
cool and slings it and wants to go back
and forth like you're not so bad you're
not so bad then we might have something
and i don't mean just this i mean for a
long time if mahomes vanquishes them and
it says and we're pissed we lost the
lamar we're going to destroy you then
the hype is going to come out of that
balloon but i want something i i the the
afc in the nfl in the united states rich
is thirsting for a bird to my home's
magic and
we have lamar he won again maybe that's
a start but he started on three herbert
winning this game would flip the table
it would mean the chiefs have lost three
out of four games and there'd be chaos
well we were talking to chris long a
couple days ago and i love him um i
don't know if you've had him on your pod
i don't know
the conversation to you guys would be
great to hear but he he said the chiefs
defense was good for the nfl because how
many times have we just gotten sick and
tired of watching the chiefs just come
up with all these crazy plays and watch
him score touchdowns by the way and his
brother's on that team you know right so
um
this this is true like i i
i
you know we we here on this show go
higher register when we need to
believe what we're saying so the higher
register comment of this week is is the
afc west wide open you know like is is
it because the only other the only
undefeated teams in the afc are in that
division and they were both supposedly
the ones who were
supposed to be on the bottom of that
division
is the asc west wide open is it possible
could it be
well do you are we including the the the
raiders is possibly would you
because i'll tell you
the rain well done well done all right
so here's quickly here's where i come
out on the raiders there's something
that's very meta about this and they're
believing in the raiders right now with
the whole las vegas experience
i feel like i need to see one more win
from them like i want to see a third win
but there's also this unwritten rule in
las vegas of don't go a third night like
the two nights are perfect and they're
wonderful and it's the time of your life
and it's intoxicating you say let's stay
one more night third night's hell you
cannot wait to get to mccarran you're
dehydrated you're bored you're broke
you're everything i just listen the rate
the raiders under gruden don't have the
equity right now i i know they beat two
really good teams fine they don't have
the equity for us to be like yeah
they're going to be great because we saw
them beat the chiefs last year and they
fell on their face there would be
nothing more raider than beating these
two teams then they beat and then losing
to the dolphins who just lost 35 to
nothing have a backup quarterback i
don't want it to happen but i can't say
i'd be shocked if it did well the monday
night opener of that stadium with fans
was like a trip to vegas where it was
wild and there were all sorts of bad
decisions that you just lamented the
next day but you still loved every
second of it and the entire crowd around
was like a star wars cantina and you
felt like you lost your shirt it just it
literally was a an entire vegas
experience in one night so i love the
concept that this is
this is the third night in vegas this is
what we'll see
we'll see what happens right yeah and
you're sleeping with six guys on the
floor at the circus circus and it's all
you can afford
and you're making bad decisions that
first night was the first night it's the
best night and i'm like god that darren
waller has 50 targets and did brooker
mcfarland just eat a shrimp on espn
and jacoby
jacoby preset this week could be mr chow
popping out of the back of the trunk
just to surprise everybody
kyle thanks for the call man appreciate
it uh eli manning when is that one drop
uh on uh ten questions okay on uh
spotify ten questions i'll record it
this afternoon and we will play the clip
from the old nfl network 2004. i can't
wait all right and which one's the
latest one that you got out there
okay we'll be the one
we're back we're back and check out
frogger right here on on peacock with
kyle brown uh kyle thanks for the call
brother you take care you go that's kyle
brand everybody
[Music]
i thought he was going that's when he's
talking about taking his ferrari for a
spin in chicago i literally thought he
was gonna go ferris bueller he left the
door open for me to walk through on that
one yeah
that's it matt maggie's cameron that's
it he's got a ferrari
what's he gonna do with it what's he
gonna do with it
is he gonna put it up on blocks and try
to roll the wheels backwards and or is
he going to take it from the mileage
it's going to be great and they're going
to have a parade with ferris bueller
right
i don't here we go he's going to take a
stand i have no idea what's going to
happen
the ferrari's going out for a spin he's
right like we better see
certainly if he tells here's anyone if
matt nagy tells the hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here